pour l'une de ses dernières conférences
de presse
my pompéo frappe un grand coup le
secrétaire d'état américain confirme
l'information du new york times selon
laquelle le numéro deux d'al qaïda a été
tué lundi dernier à téhéran et le chef
de la diplomatie américaine accuse dans
le même temps l'iran de devenir une
nouvelle base d'attache pour al qaïda al
qaïda à une nouvelle base attaches il
s'agit de la république islamique d'iran
la wac l'oeuvre diabolique de ben laden
est donc sur le point de gagner en force
et en capacité nous ignorons ce lien
entre l'iran et al qaïda à nos risques
et périls
nous devons le reconnaître nous devons
l'affronter voir le vin crainte dit
louis mas tu t'es fait en réponse la
diplomatie iranienne renvoie les
etats-unis à leurs liens avec l'arabie
saoudite de la désignation de cuba aux
accusations contre l'iran à propos d'al
qaïda monsieur menton triche on vole on
termine de façon pathétique sa carrière
désastreuse avec davantage encore de
mensonges à consonance belliqueuse
personne n'est dupe
tous les terroristes du 11 septembre
venait de destinations favorites de
mâcon paix au moyen-orient pas de liron
ce nous mentons trichons voulons c'est
une référence aux propos tenus par mike
pompéo sur son mandat à la tête de la
cia entre 2017 et 2018
l'iran avait déjà démenti tout lien avec
al qaïda
répondant aux multiples attaques de la
diplomatie américaine
et quand ce n'est pas l'iran mike pompéo
charge cuba en remettant l'île castriste
sur la liste noire des états soutenant
le terrorisme de téhéran à la havane la
politique sans concession de donald
trump aura laissé sa marque